if he's our Patsy you requesting an
arrest warrant means judicious to get
him right away that's why I'm going
as someone who's a fan of the book
series and loves TV it's been
fascinating to see how the show decides
to bring Silo to life overall I think
it's been entirely faithful to the
spirit of things changes have mostly
been in service to developing things
about the characters that'll pay off
later and halfway through the season the
butcher's boy is the point where the
Ripple effects of some of those choices
start to make it feel distinct the
episode opens where the last one left
off Juliet is in her apartment looking
at the folder that Holston left for her
in the closing shot of episode 4 it
looked as though she was seeing a ghost
as she saw his picture this was
interesting because of the limited Tech
they have access to in The Silo and
because Walker has been looking at the
camcorder that George left behind in his
box of relics that neither one of them
recognized what that was makes you
wonder why access to specific types of
tech is limited and before speculation
can go completely off the the rails
Walker provides some useful information
for both Jules and those of us that are
trying to piece it together at home
cameras exist in The Silo but they're
limited to the ones that produce low
quality images for work IDs that's where
the image of George Juliet Saul and his
folder came from and how citizens are
identified Walker also points out the
two big mysteries about The Pact as far
as she's concerned it stipulates that
they can't mechanize the way they go up
and down no lifts no pulleys and number
two no magnification above a certain
power this is a detail that came up when
Allison was trying to read the text on
the hard drive in George's apartment in
its lens his camcorder contains Tech
that clearly violates the magnification
Rule and there's mention of Juliet's
mother making something by putting two
lenses together that judicial ultimately
ended up smashing at this point in the
story you can't say why these things are
important but know they must SP after
all this is sometime in the future when
many of the things that we take for
granted like cell phones no longer exist
on top of that things that seem like
they would be fundamental to living in a
vertical environment like elevators or
things that would help to keep track of
the population like cameras are
unavailable to regular people when an
out of breath Porter brings Jules a
message from Sims telling her that Mars
is dead and that they suspect he was
murdered she rushes to the scene of the
crime there she meets her new Chief
Deputy Paul Billings who was I.T and
judicial's choice for Sheriff after
Holston went out to clean Mars had his
skull bashed in by his own shotgun and
because his door was left open and it
was a neighbor who found him Bernard
wonders if they can keep a lid on what
happened this is consistent with
something that Jules keeps learning in
this new position and something that
Sandy will make explicit later when she
says that judge Meadows doesn't give a
about the truth all she cares about
is maintaining order Sims answers to
Meadows and it seems like he has this
same point of view and he does sort of
blame this whole situation with Mars
dying on Jules for not posting someone
to watch his place Bernard diffuses
things somewhat but is firmly on the
side of keeping things quiet in an
effort to maintain order at first he
wants the official line to be that two
older people walk The Silo and it ended
up being too much for them when Jules
suggests bearing them together to
conserve resources he adds the idea of
them being in love so that that can
become the story something that will
distract people and to help out with
that he also wants to announce a race to
the top on his way out Sims tries to
throw some salt in jules's wounds by
telling her that marns thought she would
fail we know that this was in an effort
to get Sims to back down because Mars
was actually coming around to Jules but
he took that fact with him to his grave
this whole Exchange in Bernard telling
her later that that kissing judicial's
ass is the subtext of each page of The
Pact all reinforced that allies will be
hard to come by up top and from what
we've seen they don't appear to survive
long either
the funeral tells us that Bernard is not
a great public speaker and that even
though Jules isn't either her method of
saying things straight As she sees it
comes across as more honest and
highlights how everyone contributes to
making The Silo work the thing that
connects them all and that's enough to
get Sandy to lighten up after making it
clear that she still doesn't like Jules
she explains that judicial will try to
serve up a patsy and that she wants to
find out who really killed Mars she
explains that with everything that's
happened things could get disorderly
fast and she explains how things work
including the idea that judicial and
it's plan will involve getting Jewels
out and Paul Billings in as Sheriff this
puts jewels in the position that she has
to solve the case before that happens
she plans to use the list of names she
got from Mars's body to pick up where he
left off and to appease Sandy she agrees
to take Billings with her though she
pretty quickly makes an excuse to ditch
him so she can go gather information
about Patrick Kennedy who Sims had
brought up because he gave marns a
bloody nose she knows they're looking
for a patsy and that he would make a
good candidate because of his public
attack on Mars She also knows that
judicial has the wrong address for him
so she goes there and breaks into his
wife's old place where she finds rat
poison and the drawing marns made of
Mayor John's that Jules noticed was
missing from his wall knowing that
something's up she finds Kennedy at work
and takes him somewhere safe Billings
goes to sims's office where he sees
Mars's attacker who Sims introduces as
Doug Trumbull a candidate to become a
shadow it's not a huge surprise to find
out that he was from judicial but there
were indications that marns and Sims
were friends so it does feel like a
massive betrayal after Trumbull leaves
we find out that Billings isn't down
with him becoming sims's Shadow and then
they have a conversation that we don't
hear her he does go back and tells Jules
about the visit though and says that
judicial has ways to gather information
from Anonymous sources she calls them
listeners and he calls them friends of
The Silo he brings her the name of their
suspect and she realizes what judicial
is trying to do they want her to chase
down the false lead while they arrest
Kennedy for the evidence they planted
this will make her look incompetent and
enable them to replace her with Billings
instead of going after their suspect she
gets an arrest warrant for Patrick
Kennedy and then you see Doug Trumbull
go to try to get to him first Jules
knows he's somewhere safe and knows that
they had the wrong apartment so she goes
there to confront Trumbull he runs and
she chases after him through the race to
the top crowd and when he can't get away
he tries to throw her over the railing
there's a struggle he can't get her to
let go and eventually some onlookers see
what's happening and come pull her to
safety Trumbull then go goes looking for
Sims who he finds behind a door marked
janitorial this leads to a story about
his father who worked there he tells him
that everyone contributes to the
survival of the silo but a janitor is
still a janitor and explains that he
said that if he wanted to Shadow him he
would have to make a decision that would
change his life forever if he went
through that door he would never be able
to tell anyone what was on the other
side he would know the truth of what's
Happening basically his father was never
just a janitor and that the people
behind that door do the most important
work in The Silo work that he says keeps
ten thousand people alive Trumbull is
absolutely engrossed by this whole story
and then he sort of turns things around
on him saying that he really messed up
with George Wilkins which of course is
something that we want to keep in mind
Trumbull actually tries to say you know
what happened before Sims Cuts him off
and then continues saying that he really
messed things up with Patrick Kennedy he
gets him to let his guard down by saying
that he's messed up too and asks him if
he's willing to do anything to Serve and
Protect the people of The Silo when
Trumbull says he is Sims throws him over
the railing so that he can be blamed for
killing the mayor and marns and then
taking his own life this appears to be
the way Jules understands what happened
and she goes to tell the judge about it
we see that what Sandy said is true that
she really doesn't care about the truth
because she tells them not to look into
anything any further even though it
doesn't quite make sense because they
have a story that works and that
provides them the killer for these
important people that are now dead when
she goes back to her office Sandy tells
her that she put in for a transfer which
means once again she doesn't really have
anyone that's on her side and she says
some interesting things before she goes
I thought it was funny that she made the
distinction that where she lived was the
lower mids not the same as the down deep
and that there were things he was is
going to miss about the up top but one
of them was not that she feels like
she's being watched all the time Jules
asked her what she's talking about but
she doesn't really elaborate then Jules
goes to see a Tipsy Bernard who does
seem to be drinking a lot since he's
become mayor he brings up the idea that
they still need to do a forgiveness
holiday warns her that people tend to go
wild when they have those and then tells
her that he was wrong about her and it
does seem sincere I don't know if she
can trust in that but you do see why she
would be looking for someone that would
be on her side and how she might
Overlook other things that have happened
between them in order to be able to do
her job when he asks if there's anything
that she needs she says she needs two
days off and he tells her to go ahead
and take them she also runs into Lucas
again he appears to always be sitting in
the cafeteria and he explains that he
goes there to look at these lights in
the sky whenever it's clear of course
he's talking about the stars and it's
interesting to think think that they
don't really understand what they are
he's also noticed that they move and he
has some theories about that and that
gives us a little bit more backstory on
how they understand the world around
them I guess even if it doesn't exactly
explain what's going on out there as
mentioned before she does visit Walker
and she tells her that she believes that
Bernard trusts her now and mentions that
if she uses the right bait she can
figure out what happened to George she
returns to a secret hiding place she
opens his box and the episode ends with
her looking at the Pez dispenser Relic
so as I said there are a lot of things
here that are hard to line up exactly
from what happened in the books this
isn't a bad thing because they don't
fundamentally change the story and they
actually make it so book readers aren't
exactly sure what's going to happen next
without going into spoilers Sims was a
character in the books but he wasn't
that important and judicial didn't play
an active role in influencing things
around The Silo I think the fact that
they were behind Mars's death and the
introduction of the Janitor's Closet
were the two big reveals in this episode
so it's interesting that both of these
are connected to Sims if I were Jules
and I was looking for answers about what
happened to George I would certainly be
looking at him and we get another reveal
here that he did have something to do
with that Jules has been established to
be single-minded to some degree so it's
not likely that she's ever going to stop
looking for the truth of what happened
to him seeing that they're killing
people across the Spectrum regardless of
status you you have to wonder what is
motivating judicial the speech to
Trumbull was inspired and it made it
seem like Sims had conviction so I guess
the question is to what end I enjoyed
the way she put things together as far
as what was happening and the debrief
she had with Walker I like that she went
back to George's hiding place and that
she had a plan that isn't immediately
obvious to us on the other end I did
think it was a bit strange that they
decided to kill marne's off-screen not
because I wanted to see him die or
anything like that I mean he does die in
the book it's just under different
circumstances but more because of the
way that they ended things it didn't
really feel like an ending for the
character I go and check and see what
people are saying about the show each
week and didn't see many people that
were concerned that he might not survive
which based on what happened I have to
imagine that they were trying to present
that as a cliffhanger so it's not the
most effective thing the show's done and
I it wasn't a very big fan of the whole
railing scene with her hanging there
didn't really work for me but I do like
the added layer of mystery I really like
the relationship they're developing
between her and Walker and I'm curious
to see where they're going with some of
these things that they're introducing
like George's camera and that they can't
have magnification over a certain power
and that does seem like a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
about what you think's going on what do
you think's going on behind the door of
the Janitor's Closet who are the friends
of The Silo what is Sims up to can Jules
trust Bernard and what is her plan what
is this idea of bait that she's talking
about and where do you see things going
from here please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon